[Music]
in laurels over money news submitted
bike Shh Axe body spray I was like how
did they spell it was s HHH cage I did
yes
a brewery boss shut down a brand new pub
after hearing a customer swear ah wait
it's a bar right was it because the only
source from like monks monkeys open the
bar shut down the bar he open it I said
no no cousin mo moany no f-bombs here
only places a bar yeah like you it's not
a kindergarten he wasn't like hey you
get out he was like I'm shutting the bar
down this could never happen now I can
so enjoying it it's probably more
cussing going on in a church I'm gonna
turn this bar around if you don't stop
your cousin maybe he's an opposite drunk
you know some people like they get
really bullied drilling a drink maybe he
is belligerent but when he drinks he
gets really innocent
oh it turns that way so he's more
uptight and prude when he drinks
yeah but cousin together he's drunk
duh this 74 year old boss of UK's
largest independent brewery and pub
chain he has shut down one of its newest
establishments after he he stopped by
for a pint and he overheard some this
man telling his wife a joke it was a
secret drinker where he ended up
swearing in the joke yeah and so was
even it was a joke it wasn't even
someone be like I [ __ ] what it was I
go yeah that's why people are like it
wasn't even a thing like it was just a
part of a joke and it was the wife was
laughing like everyone around was having
a great time and all of a sudden he's
just shut down but he was offended damn
cuz he they say Millennials are
sensitive this fools 70 what for I know
a lot of guys his age that would call
him something else so the thing is that
yeah what do what's the vernacular from
that a pansy doodle yeah let's call it
that snapper snapper so they're saying
that this pub had been shut down for
years before it had opened again so it
was just like a really great thing for
the neighborhood like to just have this
new pub open so it was really there
saying this one customer said it's
really family friendly things were up
the pub was spotless and there had been
no trouble regularly a fire bar he's
autistic
oh well speaking of bikers he actually
banned motorcyclists from drinking at
this other pub because he didn't want
so-called undesirables there back in
2017
what is this Harry Potter the undesired
the deplorable --zz yeah is he trying to
treat this [ __ ] like it's a frickin
winery and it's all upscale and I think
he's just having a power crisis like
maybe in his marriage didn't work out
because she like stomped on him and yeah
guys like that yeah so then people are
like dude he's shutting the pub for one
swear word and taking all the money from
the till and safe and just left the pub
lady and landlord jobless and homeless
because they lived above the law yeah so
they're like dude they didn't even close
it for a brawl and please he runs the
biggest like jewelry chain yeah and you
did he just inherit it yeah that makes
no sense he's making such poor business
decisions and he's keep didn't hear in
it because this this brother brewery it
dates back all the way to 1758 Wow Wow
well he runs it right so he might be
appointed CEO like or whatever it is
he's not uh hereditary boss that means
he like yeah he inherited yeah see cuz
there's no way that that Brewer would be
in business that long if that's how they
lose their ground he probably has some
dementia or something like right now
we're like before he was it was okay and
then it now he like is making it makes
no sense why someone would do that
they right here is that he is known for
running his company with the rod of iron
he previously banned been bad language
and mobile phones at all mobile phones
at all 200 of its pubs to intrude let's
go in there how to encourage
conversation how are they going to
spread word of mouth that's like the
best marketing ever he's like I'm gonna
make chivalry happen no phones in the
pub have conversational swearing women
work the kitchen having a gay bar
happens we create medieval times
what's his like excuse is that he's
religious or that he just wanted to be a
family clean just wanted to be like the
good old days when he was a [ __ ] that
like a little yeah during King Arthur's
time you know leave your souls up at all
yeah I know what did you try to recreate
those scenes in the [ __ ] Game of
Thrones the bars that look like that
everyone has to dress like it's
Renaissance times and [ __ ] I went for my
27th birthday we got a party bus like 30
people and so we drank the whole way
there was just like a house how you do
it so when you showed up we all have
like fake swords it has the [ __ ] where I
know you eat with your fingers you we
almost got kicked out my brother works
everyone knows I've never been there
you never been there you gotta go I've
seen what the [ __ ] that would be the
most fun little excursion having for you
get family discount hey your birthday's
coming up kids your birthday did you
know that if you start throwing [ __ ]
they lower the [ __ ] Matt mm-hmm
because there's aminals they got like
eat there's a falcon yeah the guy and
they they give you a warning they're
like don't stick your hand up or you're
gonna get your hand [ __ ] clawed off
yeah like the talons are gonna hook it
because we did a field trip my whole
school my junior high we went there on
the bus and then we just [ __ ] but if
you are in junior high you should
subscribe
make sure to subscribe if you're injured
your high or high school college to that
or if you're middle aged or senior yeah
unless you only don't like cussing you
know they should really subscribe so you
can loosen up so you can learn you
should drink his own product
yeah just even try yes you did drink one
pint when you went in you do go in for a
plane oh maybe he should stop drinking
then maybe it was O'Doul's how do you
say like you over another joke and he's
like that's it for everybody yeah maybe
he was drinking he goes dad had it out
like although everybody get out of here
maybe he was looking for a reason you
know when you're PMSing and you're just
waiting like release of this anger that
you're like I don't have anything to be
angry about but I'm so angry and then
like you know Steve will just like
forget to empty the dishwasher or
something the brain prefers pain to
boredom scientifically Oh have your
board in a relationship you'll find
reasons to pick fights
oh I'm not bored about PMS just needs to
come out and I'm like and then I go so
sorry
no I'm sorry I'm a [ __ ] right now I'm
just I'm sorry you say that part yeah
yeah that's good I like need to get it
out first I'm like I'm so sorry it's so
that means we could beat our lovers as
long as we say sorry afterwards
that's the rule no Jonah Beatty you
ain't gotta go there
good fun time touch of your mouth like a
falcon at Renaissance Fair like yield to
my command we were scared you know
feeding me yeah just as good fed if they
are funny and it's almost lunchtime
anyway I say I'm like a feral that gets
fed by the centre well cool we're moving
on great we're talking about this pub
here and this guy who's got his penny
for a bad guy I would like to see a
photo I would like to see it yeah me too
I want to shame it yes I would like to
close something they'll be kind of Smith
stupid name concreteness I want to get
particleboard and nail all the windows
and make sure that people don't come
back into my establishment deaf intent
for stupid reasons I think that's what
he was doing he like I have the power
yeah I don't I wonder if that's for
publicity publicity shut it down for a
week we're back in business
some get some
he's actually very he's a lot of noticed
if you name anything with two animals it
just sounds classy Fox and goose yeah
the turtle and the elephant I'll meet
you at the Tiger water same with
different plants like I've purchased
different clothing items like all Ivan
big you know oh maybe what if you put an
animal with a plant so like the Fox on
your own monkey yeah monkey flower
monkey in them and that has the answer
that's the classy part to be a specific
type of monkey mm-hmm baboon in the rows
and put a little accent over the e so
it's rose a baboon that sounds like a
shampoo yeah right that's like Frenchie
it goes you have like a la or a lei
that's a luxury brand now we should open
up huh guys we should start a pub only
swearing if you don't swear you get your
pub shut down rose hey [ __ ] you give me
a [ __ ] beer [ __ ]
sounds like JK news to me yeah [ __ ]
ready yeah that's how you have to order
except I can't drink so I'll just watch
you're gonna be the one sitting I'm
sober now too
oh I've always been sober I'm like a
hundred and something days for you
thanks guys thank you support so I like
coming here take it throw [ __ ] out
[Music]